e herkese merhaba ben
tanzer 37 yaşındayım ve
İstanbulluyum 4 sene öncesine kadar
hafta içleri hayatım Aslında apartman
Plaza ve alışveriş merkezleri arasında
sıkışıp kalmıştı Fakat bugün tarımla
uğraşıyorum Evet tarım
Eee birçoğumuzun Aslında her gün
nimetlerinden faydalandığımız fakat bir
o kadar da uzak olduğumuz bir alan tarım
Ben Örneğin Eskiden 45 sene evvel
Pazartesi Ne bileyim saat 8.9 gibi ofise
yetişmek için ya metroda ya arabada
trafikte olurken bugün Adana'da portakal
bahçesinde veya ne bileyim Giresun'da
fındık bahçelerinde Vakit geçirebiliyor
daha çok doğayla iç içeyim ve
zaman zaman sokakta eski arkadaşlarımla
karşılaşıyorum diyorlar kian Sen ne işle
uğraşıyorsun abi diyorum tarımla
uğraşıyorum Nasıl yani organik tarım mı
yapıyorsun Yok hayır organik tarımla
uğraşmıyorum bildiğim tarım yapıyorum o
zaman ceviz bahçem var diyorlar Hayır
diyorum Hayır yani ceviz bahçesi de yok
ben dijital tarımla uğraşıyorum işte
bugün size biraz çiftçilikten biraz da
dijital tarımdan bahsedeceğim Fakat önce
biraz bu tarım konusunu sizlerden
içselleştirmiş
en son ne zaman çıplak ayakla bir
toprağa bastığınız hatırlayın lütfen
Tamam Geçen gün geçen ay ne bileyim
geçen sene ama kum veya çim değil
bildiğiniz Yalın topraktan bahsediyorum
kahverengi çıplak topraktan
bahsediyorum belki birçoğunuz
hatırlayamama çok problem değil Az sonra
bu salonun dışına çıkacağız Uzaklarda
Bir
Yerde Yalın ayaklarla toprağa basacağız
şimdi gözlerinizi
kapatın Az sonra ondan geriye sayacağım
ve bu salonun dışına
çıkacağız Çukurova'da bir tarlanın
yanına
gideceğiz 10
8 göz kapaklarınız ağırlaşıyor şu anda
salonun
dışındasınız
5 sıcak ılık bir rüzgar yüzünüze
çarpıyor akşamüstü çukur ovasın
2 ayaklarınız çıplak bir çınar ağacının
alt
Toprak hafif ıslak parçaları ayağınızı
gıdıklıyor 10 gün önce yine
Buradaydın tarlanıza pamuk tohumlarını
ektiniz şu anda tarlanız karşısında ve
uçsuz bucaksız tarlanızı
seyrediyorsunuz tarlanızı dinleyebiliyor
musunuz hissediyor
musunuz
Evet tarla her ne kadar boş gibi gözükse
de
toprağın ü parmak altında on binlerce
pamuk tohumu Hummalı bir faaliyet
içindeler bir
yandan toprağın derinliğindeki besinleri
ve suyu çekebilmek için köklerini aşağı
doğru salarken Diğer
yandan güneşe ulaşabilmek için çimlerini
yeryüzüne doğru
yükseltiyorlar bugün siz
ilk çimleri görmek için tarlanız
başındasınız lütfen gözlerinizi
açın
Evet 180 günlük bir sürecin ilk ve en
önemli adımıdır çimlenme Eğer
tarlanızdır Önümüzdeki 180 gün boyunca
tarlanıza gün aşırı gideceksiniz
bitkiniz yeteri kadar büyüyor mu suyu
yeterli mi işte bitkinin gelişimini
engelleyecek zararlı ot var mı veya bir
yabancı varlık var mı Bunları düzenli
kontrol etmek zorundasınız çoğumuzun
alıştığı ofis işlerinden farklı yani
sabah 8 akşam 5 5 gün boyunca full time
çalıştığınız işlerden oldukça farklıdır
çiftçilik bu 180 gün boyunca belki
sadece 2530 gün Tam zamanlı
çalışacaksınız ama ama çalıştığınız
zaman da gerçekten çalışacaksınız sabah
6'dan gece 12'ye kadar çalışacaksınız bu
ama tarlanız uzaklaş anlamına gelmiyor
Çünkü en önemli yaptığınız işlerden bir
tanesi tarladaki gözlemler eğer o
gözlemlerden bir tanesini kaçırırsanız
bir ilacı geç attınız diyelim veya bir
gübreyi geç verdiniz diyelim bütün
mahsulünü riske girebilir o mahsul de
sene sonunda Sezon sonunda hasatta
alacağınız mahsul de sizin bir sene
içindeki tek gelir kaynağınız alacağınız
mahsüle belki çocuklarınızın eğitimine
para harcayacaksın evinizin eksiklerini
tamamlayacaksınız bir sonraki hasata
kadar geçiminizi sağlayacaksınız Ha bir
de bir kenara bir para ayıracaksınız ki
bir sonraki sene tekrar tarlanızı
ekebilir Her şey bu bahsettiğim her şey
çimlenmeden hasata kadar düzgün bir
mahsul alabilmek ve hayatınızı
ettirebilmek
için az önce bahsettiğim hikayeyi
Türkiye'de yaşayan 3 milyon Çiftçi var
çiftçilerin aileleri ve yanlarında
çalışan insanlarla beraber kabaca 1314
milyon insandan bahsediyoruz yani
Türkiye'de her 6 kişiden bir tanesi
toprağın şu veya bu şekilde Pardon
rızkını şu veya bu şekilde topraktan
kazanıyor bu oldukça büyük bir ek
62 milyar dolarlık bir ekonomiden
bahsediyoruz 62 milyar doları
anlayabiliyor musunuz 62 milyar dolara
Siz Konya ovasının % 70'ini sulay
abilir Anadolu'nun tüm şehirlerini Demir
yoluyla birbirine bağlayabilirsiniz bu
kadar büyük bir endüstri olmasına rağmen
bu kadar büyük bir sektör olmasına
rağmen gıdaya her an ucuza
erişebildiğinizi
algısı katma değersizmiş gibi
algılanıyor
Bu sadece tarım için geçerli değil
medeniyetin bize sunduğu diğer nimetler
için de benzeri şeyler geçerli bir
şekilde bunları kanıksamış durumdayız
Örneğin ulaşım bugün Türkiye'nin
herhangi bir yerine en geç 2 saat içinde
ulaşabiliyorsunuz veya
iletişim Çok uzun zamandır görmediğiniz
Arkadaşlarınızı bile başka kıtalarda
otursalar bile sosyal medya aracılığıyla
ulaşıp konuşabiliyorsunuz ne var ne yok
nasıl gidiyor hayatları
öğrenebiliyorsunuz
elektrik Gecelerimizi aydınlatan
fabrikalarımız enerji veren elektrik 2
hafta öncesini hatırlayın lütfen çok
değil 2 hafta önce Türkiye'nin % 70'ine
12 saat boyunca enerji verilemedi bir
hatırlayın o gün neler
yaşadınız metrolar çalışmadı Fabrikalar
durdu hastanelerin sadece acil
servislerine enerji verildi belki
toplantınız işinize geç kaldınız Hayat
felç oldu değil mi hatırlıyorsunuz Ama
hayat devam etti
durmadı bir de tarımın olmadığını hayal
edin yarın gıda Yok bir şey oldu şehre
İstanbul'a 5 gün gıda
gelmedi Ne yaparsınız hayat o zaman o
kadar kolay devam etmeyebilir Hayati
risk altında
olabilirsiniz O
yüzden biz bize bu nimetleri sunan
çiftçilerin daha iyi şartlar altında
yaşamaları gerektiğine inanıyoruz ve
teknolojiyi kullanarak
onların gelirlerini arttırmaya
odaklanıyoruz Bunu sadece Çiftçiler için
yapmıyoruz bunu aynı zamanda Biz
şehirlerde yaşayan insanlar için de
yapıyoruz en
son bilmiyorum herhangi bir köyün
içinden geçtiyseniz nelere dikkat
ettiniz örnek Yani şu anda Bahar
mevsimindeyiz Evet çiçekler var Belki
Kuzular koyunlar görüyorsunuz etraf
güzel kokuyor her tarafta ekili
tarlaları görüyorsunuz
fakat insanlara dikkat ettiniz mi
bilmiyorum ya bir daha gittiğinizde
lütfen edin köylerde genç
yok gittiğiniz zaman köylerde sadece
yaşlı insanları görüyorsunuz Türkiye'nin
nüfus yaş ortalaması 2728 civarında
çiftçilerin yaş ortalaması 54 artık
gençler çiftçilik yapmıyorlar bizim
tarımın genç nesiller tarafından
üstlenilmesi için bugünden harekete
geçmemiz lazım
ve gençlerin bu işi benimsemesini
sağlamamız lazım Bu sadece Türkiye'nin
problemi değil aynı zamanda dünyanın da
problemi Çünkü kalabalıklaşıyor
2050'ye kadar 9.1 milyar kişi
olacağız ve sadece nüfus artmayacak
nüfusla beraber gelir de artacak
insanlar daha fazla şeyler talep
edecekler et talep edecekler süt talep
edecekler çikolata isteyecekler ve biz
dünyayı sınırlarında kullanıyoruz daha
fazla tarım arazimiz yok gerçekten çok
daha azını
çıkartabiliriz Dolayısıyla bugünden
2050'ye kadar birim alandan aldığımız
verimi 1.6 katına çıkartmamız lazım bu
1.6 kat hataya çok yer yok demek
aslında ama bu ne kadar zor olursa olsun
mümkün artışın 0' yapısal
değişikliklerden gelecek Yani şöyle
söyleyeyim su genişletilmesi veya modern
tarım aletlerinin hasat makinelerinin
tarıma girmesinden gelecek ama çok
önemli bir kısmı tarımda bilginin
kullanılmasından gelecek çiftçilerin
bilinçlenmesi işi bilerek bilimsel
yapmalarından gelecek üst üste Ekinleri
aynı Ekinleri ekip toprağı
çoraklaşmak
gelecek işte biz bunun için her gün
hayatımızda bizlerin kullandığı işte
internet akıllı telefon gibi
teknolojileri
alıyoruz sahadan topladığımız bilgilerle
meteoroloji
istasyonlarından veya traktörlerden
gelen bilgilerle birleştiriyoruz bunları
tarımsal bilgilerle
İyiler Fakat o kadar üst üste
yetiştirmişler ki artık bazı işleri
oldukça ezb
yapıyorlar pamuğun başlıca
düşmanlarından bir tanesi pembe kurt bu
kadar münik gözüktüğü bakmayın tarlaya
girdiğin zaman gerçekten Duman ediyor
Yani bir hafta verin ona hiç hucum
bırakmıyor ve peme kurt genelde Temmuz
ayının ilk haftasında çıkıyor Sökeli
Çiftçiler de her Temmuzun ilk haftasında
mutlaka ezberi ilaçlarını atıyorlar 2010
yılında yine temmuzda ilaç L attılar bir
baktılar Ağustos başında Tarlalarda
pamukların çiçekleri yeniyor a pemt ya
evet pembe kurt işte dijital tarım bu
pembe kurtun Hayat döngüsünü takip edip
hangi sene ne zaman çıkacağını söyleyen
teknolojidir dijital tarım Kuzey
atlantikteki su sıcaklığı 23 derece
düştüğü zaman Türkiye'nin sert bir kış
geçireceğini ve buğday rekoltesinin % 6
arasında artacağını söyleyen
teknolojidir bugün bu teknolojiyi yani
sunduğumuz hizmetlerden 50.000 Çiftçi
faydalanıyor 50.000 50.000 bir internet
girişimiyle karşılaştırdığınızda
ne problemleri var Dolayısıyla Bayağı
büyük bir
sayım ben bu 50.000 kişiden binlerce
hikaye olmasına rağmen beni çok
etkileyen bir kişinin hikayesini
anlatacağım Hasan abinin hikayesi Hasan
abi Denizli'de yaşıyor Hasan abinin 3
tane çocuğu var bu ü çocuğunu 6 tane
ineğinin sütünü sağarak ve onu satarak
geçindiriyor
Ayrıca Hasan abinin evinin Arkasında iki
dönüm arazi var ik Dönüm ne demek
biliyor musunuz kabaca bu salondan ik
tane
düşünebilirsiniz bu tarım için hiçbir
şey demek iki dönüme buğday ekerseniz
senede belki 600 lir kazanırsınız ya da
650 lira çok para
kazanmazsa
süt hayvanlarını besleyebilmek için
silajlık Mısır ekiyor Mısır silajı da
süt besisinde çok çok önemli bir yem
çünkü sizin yem maliyetinizi yarı yarıya
düşürüyor Biz Hasan abi tanıştı 7
senedir o tarlaya silajlık Mısır
ekiyordu ve decar yani Bir dönüme 2 bu5
ton falan ürün alıyordu Biz atladık
Denizli'ye gittik Hasan abiyi ziyaret
ettik dedik Abim bir toprağına bakabilir
miyiz suyunu analiz edebilir miyiz Ha
bir de iklim değerlerine bakalım son 5
senede ne olmuş bütün bunları inceledik
dediki Hasan abi sen ne yapmışsın ya
Yani bu tohum senin bölgene uygun değil
al abi Lütfen bu tohumu kullan dedik ve
sen tekrar konuşalım dedik bugün Hasan
abi 6,5 ton alıyor bir karar bir bilgi
arkasında bilim ve teknoloji koyduğunuz
zaman gerçekten insanların hayatını
değiştirebiliyor ve ben gerçekten 4 sene
önce bu bunun için yola çıktım yani
insanların hayatını değiştirebilmek için
yola
çıktım cebimde ilk çıktığımda yola
sadece bir fikir vardı Bu fikir Tarım da
iş yapış şeklini değiştirmek üzerine bir
fikirdi
ve ben aslında fikirleri de tohumlara
benzetiyorum 4 sene önce kendi fikrime
ektim bugün yeşerdi ve 50.000 kişi benim
fikrime yani Bu fikre inanıyor Belki
yarın buna Milyonlar inanacak son olarak
söylemek istediğim Eğer bir fikriniz
varsa eğer gerçekten o fikre
inanıyorsanız Bence vakit kaybetmeyin
peşine düşün takip edin teşekkür
[Alkış]
ederim